now a public meeting is underway to
gather input on a state law that
requires the county to allow short-term
rentals now currently they're not even
permitted in unincorporated clark county
but that hasn't stopped them and now the
county has to regulate short-term
rentals by july sally jaramillo on this
story join us live from d-i and lindell
with more on the short-term rental
salary a lot of mixed opinions on this
issue
yeah just to give you some perspective
there are four airbnb homes in this
particular neighborhood and while you
may want to rent out your home to make
some extra money many of your neighbors
don't want you to do that
i love it because
it allows people like myself serial
entrepreneurs to
have access to a property reynaldo
herrera says this property has been an
airbnb for six months before kovit and
before the laws changed it was an airbnb
for about a year and a half it allows me
to
use it as a resources a resource for
business partners as well as make
passive income herrera says he also has
airbnbs in oaxaca mexico and central
california weekend like edc weekend i
mean it gave us great profit margins
because of the demand but right now it's
been limited to it rents out one whole
month and it won't run out for two
months herrera is now questioning if he
should do a traditional rental again i
miss the old days where we can just rent
it out for two to three days like every
other airbnb now
there's restricted there's zoning issues
cindy kester is the vice president for
camco she provides management services
to hoas in nevada and represents over
300 associations she is against these
rentals we don't want short-term rentals
in our community it's everything
we deal with that already with the
partying the loud music excess vehicles
access control because that means what
anybody that have gates you're giving
out gate codes kester is concerned the
weekend visitors could bring down
property values it's an invitation for
problems being limited to enterprise
like other counties is just it's just an
awful restriction
back out live herrera tells me he's
never had any issues or complaints with
his airbnbs and he hopes today's meeting
brings out a better outcome reporting
live sally haramiyo live local now